hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 12 video
and since they made the big announcement
about Marvel not going to comic-con I'll
explain that too there's a lot of stuff
going on in the Marvel Universe right
now just to start with a comic-con stuff
I know that was a big WTF for everyone
so here's the deal
James Gunn did a facebook Q&A like he
does every once in a while where someone
asked him if he was going to San Diego
comic-con and he replied I don't think
that Marvel is going so I'm probably not
going either
I'm not really sure so everyone was kind
of like wait what did he just say Marvel
isn't going to comic-con that's kind of
a big deal
cut forward to like another day or so
and he was like no I wasn't lying to the
fans I'm pretty sure Marvel is not going
that's why most of the actual news
reporters in Hollywood right now are
reporting that Marvel isn't going to
comic-con they haven't made it official
Marvel isn't going to say anything about
this definitively like they'll either
show up or they won't but they're
probably not gonna do a big Hall H panel
just add a little bit of context Comic
Con was moved way up to the beginning of
July this year they have ant-man coming
out like a couple weeks after that so by
the time comic-con hits
they'll have already spent most of their
marketing budget on the movie so there's
there's really no point in them
marketing the movie at Comic Con they
don't gain anything from it plus they
already did their big phase 3 panel
earlier this year where they announced
all the movies that are coming out in
the next four or five years so they
don't need to do that again they've
already done that
on top of that because Marvel is Disney
Disney owns D 23 they might be doing
some presentations at d23 this year that
doesn't mean that Marvel is never gonna
do a haul age panel at Comic Con again
it just means that they're almost
powerful enough like they almost have
enough of a marketing machine that they
don't need comic-con like they have
their own conventions that they can do
this at I think it's actually a really
good idea it certainly makes my weekend
at comic-con a lot easier Marvel as a
studio does not benefit as much from
comic-con as other Studios do so it just
doesn't make as much sense for them to
spend a ton of money if they're not
going to be promoting anything specific
I'll post more updates about Marvel
comic con stuff in the future if they
release any official updates but but
don't worry it's not going to be a huge
deal so on to agents of shield just
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet if you guys
didn't recognize them Eddie McLintock
was the Kree soldier in this episode so
I'm gonna explain him first and what he
means about the
TV universe because it's kind of a
Guardians crossover but not really like
they said some very specific things in
the episode that made it seem like
they're not gonna do something like this
again his name in the episode was vin
tak that is not a character from the
comics but it is a sign that Marvel is
slowly bringing cosmic stories and
earth-based stories together as you can
imagine this is a road map to the end of
phase 3 in Avengers infinity war where
the Avengers will have a cosmic story
whereas right right now they're having
mostly earth-based stories as SIF said
at the end of the episode I'm going to
take him back to holla his home planet
they won't bother you again
that probably means we won't be seeing a
whole lot of other Kree on agents of
shield Coulson said don't worry I'll
track down the rest of these diviners so
the rest of this season is going to be
tracking down all the other Inhumans
obviously the teaser for the next
episode applies we're gonna meet a whole
bunch of them maybe not all of them but
definitely most of them so it's a little
bit of them winking at the audience it's
like yes this is going on in outer space
cosmic things you know tides of the
universe as SIF said are influencing
what's happening on earth but they're
not gonna be happening on earth all the
time
and yes the Bobby Mac stuff the secret
planning probably secret warriors from
the comics I don't think it's Secret
Avengers I think that'll happen like
after Captain America Civil War that's
part of my top 5 moments oh don't worry
I'll totally explain it so top five
moments number five welcome back to SIF
they buried the lede a little bit but
SIF was following vintag to earth to
keep him from taking the diviners or at
least trying to find out what it was he
was looking for she kept saying the word
kava that is the Kree word for keys they
ended up going back to the original dig
site where they found the diviners in
the in the first episode remember where
Whitehall had that case so this episode
is a direct link to that flashback to
the agent Carter flashback in episode 1
I always give the writers a giant high
five when they're able to tie the ark
back to big WTF moments in the first
couple of episodes also some of the
funniest moments in the episode some of
the funniest jokes were agent May
talking to SIF about stuff that she
couldn't remember like Thor I don't know
why but this name makes me smile and
then you see agent May just smile
herself and go I know exactly why she's
smiling Odin yeah you've totally met
Odin
you guys are bros I cheered a little bit
when she said that because remember Loki
has been posing as Odin since the end of
dark world so if he sent SIF on this
mission to find the diviners it was
actually Loki sending her on the mission
we will definitely talk more about
what's going on with Loki and Asgard
because it'll tie in with Avengers age
of Ultron and Thor Ragnarok but but
that's not gonna happen for a while so
add a tab and chrome will come back to
that later
don't worry on to number four Bobby and
Mac teased a new secret organization
inside shield probably the secret
warriors I was really happy they added a
lot of context to this secret Bobby Mac
plot the language she used is very
important she said remember what
happened when we found out our friends
were Hydra and then Mac said we are not
Hydra that implies that whatever shadow
organization that they have running is
not bad they're not evil for those that
haven't read the comics there are many
secret organizations inside shield
there's sort although technically that's
another secret that's kind of like a
cosmic space based version of shield I
don't think that that's what they're
doing
there's also secret warriors which is
like a big comic book line and then
there's Secret Avengers all of those
things kind of tie in around like The
Secret Invasion Dark Reign era of the
comic books what I think is going on
what I think they're doing is secret
warriors just because the showrunners
would not stop talking about secret
warriors last year like they were huge
fans of that storyline in the comics and
Daisy Johnson the the character from the
comics that Skye is that they turned her
into the inhuman she is part of the
secret warriors team if you guys have a
Marvel unlimited subscription you can
totally read that secret warriors
storyline for free so check it out on to
number three everyone figures out that
Skye is one of the Inhumans I'm so happy
they didn't drag this reveal out nothing
is worse than a TV show teasing us with
someone having super awesome powers and
then never letting the character have
fun with them I was a little worried
with the way Skye was acting whenever
the show came back like she was she was
in quarantine she started to freak out
you want karnak to come judo slap her
silly get a hold of yourself you have
awesome powers have some fun now that
the whole team knows about it they can
deal with it and they can get there much
quicker so by the end of the season I
think Skye will have a better command of
her abilities she'll be more self
assured not right away half the group is
still freaking out about it which is a
little frustrating but they'll get over
it you can look at it as like a minor
tease for Civil War from the common
but but that's not what's going on there
was a lot of language that sounded very
civil war esque like these people are
freaks no these people are humans we
need to regulate them we need to lock
them away Civil War in the comics if you
haven't read it you could also read it
all Marvel unlimited it's all about the
idea of superhero Registration Captain
America Civil War the movie is gonna be
different from that on to number two
meet VIN Tec Cree firm holla most of you
guys are probably familiar with the Cree
from guardians of the galaxy Ronan the
accuser was a creep but he was part of
the accuser Corps and he was a fanatic
so he's like a crazy example of the
creek there are creed that are totally
normal totally nice people FinTech
explains he's just trying to help he's
just trying to take the diviners so that
they can't create more quote-unquote
monstrosities I'll explain that in a
second because there's a lot of extra
context to be out of there Eddie
McLintock awesome actor I'm totally sad
warehouse 13 got cancelled he was a
little ridiculous I mean I like him when
he's playing it a little straighter he's
a great comedic actor to explain the
monstrosity thing so there is like a
subform of Inhumans that are more
genetically deformed than others they
try to prevent that with selective
breeding genetic tailoring is a really
important idea for the Inhumans they
practiced thousands of years of
selective breeding so they can create
better Inhumans but every once in a
while you get like someone who's really
really deformed you could look at that
as a teaser for Raina because she is
more physically deformed but the wave
intact used the term in the episode he
calls them all monstrosity so like even
Skye who looks you know totally normal
is a monstrosity by his definition they
do stray a little bit into after-school
special territory when they're like okay
you're not deformed you're special
like in the last episode when the reader
rescued Raina and he says hello
beautiful he himself is you know
obviously a little bit deformed I'm not
a huge fan when they get really on the
nose with with their morality like this
like it's like yeah of course everyone
is supposed to be special we get it
really though my number one WTF awesome
moment was when Vin tech explained the
kree-skrull war and terrigenesis
I've already done a lot of videos on the
Inhumans so I'll add some links in the
description but the kree-skrull war was
where the Inhumans story was born out of
like Stan Lee created it and then kind
of weaved it into that the Kree were
trying to create a super
to use as a weapon against the scrolls
obviously the scrolls kind of exist in
the fantastic foreign universe it's a
little up in the air as to whether or
not Marvel has the rights to use them
that's why Joss Whedon used the shatori
in the Avengers film otherwise it would
have been a scroll invasion vintag
actually spelled it out pretty clearly
the Kree at a certain point realized
that the Inhumans as a project we're
going downhill like they were gonna
result in something really terrible
happening so they just abandoned it they
just like kind of closed up shop
you know lock the doors and walked away
and the Inhumans were left to themselves
that was thousands of years ago so at
slant like you know the royal family
Black Bolt they all arose out of an
independent society that evolved on
their own so the Kree today don't have a
whole lot of interaction with the
Inhumans and yes Atalanta is out there
they just haven't introduced it in the
film universe I will be interested to
see if they mention it by name on the
series probably not I'm not expecting it
but they might here's my big question
for you guys if they could have any more
like cosmic cameos like stuff from the
guardians of the galaxy universe on the
TV show who would you want to see now
remember like they're probably not gonna
have Chris Pratt or anyone like that but
any you know alien races who do you want
to see on agents of shield I think the
next logical step would be for Coulson
to make jokes about talking dogs like
Cosmo or Howard the Duck just jokes I
don't think there's any way we're gonna
see him on the show here's some of the
bigger Easter eggs I saw there was a
whole bunch of loaded comments loaded
dialogue it was a lot of fun starting
off with full mortal combat so next week
Kevin Tancharoen he's the brother of
showrunner Marissa tan Chiron is going
to be directing he is the one who
started the Mortal Kombat web series at
machinima a long long time ago he was
gonna do a Mortal Kombat reboot movie
but he passed on the project after a
while
so Kevin Tanner on Mortal Kombat 2
Mortal Kombat reference in the episode
when bobbi and Hunter had that sex scene
and he said then you turn into a bit of
a nightmare
she actually she got mind control she
got brainwashed in the comics the
Mockingbird character and was evil for a
while so she literally turned into
something of a nightmare I already
explained the SIF Loki Odin stuff but
when she says only seven species across
the nine realms require nitrogen to
breathe she was talking about the Badoon
the brood the dire wraiths the failing
the Shiar the scrolls very clearly
Marvel does not have the film and TV
rights for all of those races but but
most of them so it's just a nice teaser
for things that they could always
introduce at some point I know everyone
really liked the hammer jokes there were
so many hammer jokes in this episode
especially the little tiny hammer that
Eddie McLintock was carrying around I
don't think that he's part of the
accuser Corps but Kree do have weapons
and armor the accuser court that's
coated for them like he said only he
could operate it Ronan's hammer from
guardians of the galaxy is a slightly
different one is it's like a little bit
more powerful it's called a universal
weapon but most of the accuser Corps
have hammers like that and huge
congratulations to the winner of my
Avengers age of Ultron trailer giveaway
it's just a subscription to the
collector Corps that's Marvel's Funko
pop a subscription service it's the only
way to get the Hulkbuster pop please
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact info so like I
said I put more links in the description
for my videos on the Kree guardians of
the galaxy stuff and the Inhumans well
you guys wait for next week's episode
you can click here to catch up on agents
of shield if you guys are behind and you
can click here for the last age of
Ultron trailer starting to get a little
bit cooler than the previous trailers
lots more Ultron and the vision thank
you so much for watching so let's all do
the thing I'll see you guys tonight
you